[Musica]
al giorno d'oggi la gente conosce il
prezzo di tutto è il valore di niente
queste parole sono state scritte nel
1890 da oscar wilde nel suo romanzo il
ritratto di dorian gray questa
contrapposizione fra prezzi e valori è
un elemento centrale per molti
ragionamenti che noi economisti oggi
facciamo un ragionamento che ci serve
anche come spunto ad esempio per
ripensare l'economia
magari giocando sui colori l'economia
tradizionale normalmente viene chiamata
brown economy economia ma rompe certe
volte anche grigia ma preferirei marron
come il suolo di questo vigneto e
l'economia che ci ha dato benessere ma
che anche creato grandi problemi in
particolare in campo ambientale
e allora ecco perché si sta cercando una
nuova prospettiva ad esempio usando i
colori si parla di green economy
economia verde un'economia che cerca di
essere maggiormente in sintonia con
quelli che sono i ritmi di questo
pianeta dei degli ecosistemi
oppure qualcuno anche proposto la blue
economy
qualche volta intesa come economia del
mare ma io qui la intendo come green
economy 2.0
che cosa vuol dire cercare di immaginare
di realizzare un'economia maggiormente
in sintonia anzi in simbiosi che imita i
ritmi i modi della natura questi
cambiamenti di colore all'economia
in certi casi si usa anche
cambiare la forma dalla lineare la
circolare hanno portato a dei benefici a
dei risultati positivi
recentemente per esempio in campo
ambientale è stato ricordato che
l'economia ha garantito una maggiore
estensione una maggiore numerosità di
aree protette su questo pianeta
la maggior destinazione di risorse in
particolare pubbliche per la tutela
delle risorse naturali ha permesso di
conoscere maggiormente le specie animali
presenti su questa terra ma rovescio
della medaglia ha continuato a generare
problemi perdite di habitat che
costantemente procedono pensate ai
boschi un uso della chimica in
particolare in agricoltura che in certi
casi genera problemi oppure la perdita
irreversibile di specie l'estinzione
delle specie
in altri termini il fatto di aver
ricolorato l'economia non ha risolto del
tutto i problemi ce ne sono ancora di
molti e allora
poniamoci alcune domande proviamo a
chiederci se l'economia potrà mai
immaginare se stessa come un processo
so che riesce ad essere a favore
insisto sulla componente ambientale a
favore di quello che chiamiamo il
capitale naturale che è quella struttura
che il pianeta terra e le sue componenti
che ci fornisce un flusso di benefici
che chiamiamo servizi ecosistemici in
cui è presente una forte
caratterizzazione in termini di
biodiversità e allora il tema su cui
porre l'attenzione può essere proprio
questo
riuscirà l'economia sta almeno iniziando
a farcela ad inserire al proprio interno
far diventare proprio questo equilibrio
dei propri ritmi con quelli
dell'ambiente
ci sono delle risposte a questo quesito
è una di queste risposte
vorrei proporvela qui oggi ed è quella
di cercare di misurare di valutare
l'ambiente è una strada è un percorso in
pratica significa riprendere proprio
quella suggestione da cui sono partito
la citazione di oscar wilde può essere
una strada quella di cercare di curvare
di adattare l'economia alle esigenze
degli equilibri ambientali fare in modo
che l'economia tenga conto
il capitale naturale del suo valore dei
servizi ecosistemici della biodiversità
in altre parole possiamo immaginare che
l'economia riesca a dare un prezzo a
valori che prezzo non hanno e capire se
e quando questo sforzo valutativo può
esserci utile
è un percorso che si sta cercando che si
sta esplorando da diverso tempo e ed è
molto interessante vedere che questo
tipo di approccio
lo ritroviamo anche in contesti per noi
che ce ne occupiamo come attività
professionale nella ricerca lo
ritroviamo in contesti sorprendenti
vi voglio portare un esempio in questo
senso
ed è questo un fumetto
questo è un fumetto disegnato da bill
waterson questa striscia che vi presento
oggi è stata pubblicata in italia nel
2004 ma risale al 1995 anche questo
disegnatore in quell'anno decise di
salutare i suoi personaggi era stato
sopraffatto da loro per cui è una delle
ultime strisce che vedono per
protagonista il bambino pestifero calvi
6 anni e il suo adorato pupazzo di pezza
questa tigre che per lui è vera e il suo
interlocutore sta passeggiando nei
dintorni di casa propria e fa questo
commento si parla continuamente dello
sfruttamento di nuovi territori selvaggi
per lo sviluppo
e aggiunge evidentemente comprendiamo il
valore del petrolio del legname e dei
minerali delle abitazioni
tutti elementi che hanno un prezzo
perché passano per un mercato ma non
quello della bellezza incontaminata
della fauna in libertà della solitudine
del rinnovamento spirituale
a questo punto c'è il commento di hobbes
della sua amata tigre dobbiamo
cominciare a mettere i prezzi sulle cose
senza prezzo
e allora caldi di fronte a questa
proposta con entusiasmo dice già se i
nostri boschi valgono un figlio né
decisione di barbie glioni pensa cosa
vale l'alaska in una striscia di un
fumetto
penso di questa strada che ristò
prospettando in un certo senso poi gli
economisti ambientali come anch'io in
parte appunto sono hanno preso spunto
probabilmente anche ispirato questo
ragionamento e lo fanno da un po di
tempo cercando proprio di dare un prezzo
le cose senza prezzo
e questo avviene a livello
internazionale avviene a livello
nazionale anche locale
l'ispirazione di calvin ci ha portato
come economisti ad affrontare questo
tema prendo l'acqua come esempio la cona
risorsa lo sappiamo è un qualcosa su cui
si basa la vita su questo pianeta ma è
anche in grado di aiutarci non solo noi
gli esseri viventi a liberarci dagli
scarti liberarci dei rifiuti pensate al
problema epocale delle plastiche negli
oceani ma è anche un esempio di risorsa
che in grado di fornirci direttamente
un'utilità immaginiamoci davanti ad un
bellissimo tramonto sul mare oppure
mentre osserviamo lo scorrere di questo
fiume o ascoltiamo il suono e sentiamo i
profumi di una cascata
questa è un'utilità un benessere un
beneficio che otteniamo senza la
mediazione di nessuno ebbene queste tre
grandi categorie riassumono quelle che
noi chiamiamo le funzioni economiche
dell'ambiente sono funzioni economiche
che creano esemplificano un problema
perché spesso riguardano aspetti che non
passano per un mercato che non hanno un
prezzo e allora il tentativo di
soluzione
recentemente ho letto questo titolo
l'orso yoghi fa meglio della finanza
speculativa
cosa vorrà mai dire il sistema di
gestione pubblica dei parchi naturali
nord americani da anni fa un report che
fra le altre cose da regolarmente questa
misurazione per ogni dollaro che il
sistema americano nordamericano pubblico
mette nel sistema dei parchi genera un
ritorno economico per il sistema
statunitense di 12 dollari 1 12 un
messaggio importante messaggio forte
usando il metodo monetario con cui
abbiamo familiarità a livello nazionale
un esempio
questi sono sei aree protette aree
marine protette del nostro paese è stato
misurato qual è il valore del beneficio
netto generato il più alto e 50 milioni
di euro all'anno e anche quant'è il
valore di questo beneficio netto
rapportato alla superficie agli ettari
si arriva anche a 33 mila euro
all'ettaro valutazione in questo caso in
euro che cosa significa dare questi
valori vendere questi prodotti sul
mercato no significa darci un segnale
chiaro comprensibile su cosa
significherebbe se noi non facessimo
queste azioni di tutela quale sarebbe la
perdita comunicando ce l'ha con un metro
familiare ancora un esempio locale siamo
in un contesto di questo genere ripetuto
più volte un laboratorio con dei ragazzi
e delle ragazze tra i 16 ei 22 anni 230
persone in più sessioni abbiamo
coinvolto in questo esperimento anche
noi economisti facciamo gli esperimenti
erano invitate invitati ad assaggiare
dei succhi di frutta succo d'uva le foto
in alto succo di mela le foto in basso
in bicchierini anonimi solo numerati si
proponeva una diversa origine della
materia prima per l'uva un succo con
l'uva che derivava dal vigneto di
sinistra l'altro succo dal vigneto di
destra così per lamela è per il succo di
mela
ebbene l'assaggio abbinato a questa
informazione determinava un maggiore
apprezzamento dei succhi riferiti al
contesto ambientale paesaggistico un
servizio eco sistemico di destra che
sapevamo lo avevamo valutato essere
maggiormente gradito ma non basta
l'assaggio del succo determinava anche
una maggiore disponibilità a pagare se
avessero potuto comperare quei succhi di
frutta diversi sul mercato nel
distributore automatico l'avrebbero
pagato di più ebbene credo sia
prevedibile che il succo che veniva
assaggiato era lo stesso era più buono
veniva anche valutato in euro di più
perché abbinato ad un contesto
paesaggistico a un ambiente migliore in
questo caso più bello la dimensione
estetica richiamata da calvin prima
ritorno ad un'immagine di colori per
chiudere con una considerazione è meglio
una valutazione economica magari
monetaria come quella che vi ha proposto
anche imprecisa piuttosto di una
valutazione nascosta con cui vengono
comunque prese delle decisioni
magari da noi come consumatori ma anche
decisioni più ampie più importanti ma
che non sono trasparenti che non si
basano su valori a noi visibili
chiaramente grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]